okay the annual meeting of the world
they're coming forum just closed here in
Davos Switzerland I'm with you know
normal ass she brought you all those
presidents and prime ministers in front
of this webcam and Pablo Camacho the
citizen reporter from YouTube we're at
the World Economic Forum I extremely
grateful to all your contributions 260
videos from the YouTube community and to
the 125 Davos participants who replied
to your videos and joined the Davos
debates it's amazing I think overall to
today 2.7 million people have already
watched these videos so it's a it's a
great success and I can tell you that
David Miliband has pledged to bring
these towers debates to the g20 summit
in London which is absolutely great so
and I hope we can continue these these
discussions these debates here on
YouTube and so I want to thank you all
want to thank you also the people from
myspace and Rebecca me quake was was a
myspace reporter here and all the people
on facebook and participated in the
policy of for the annual meeting so the
debates are not over the debates the
discussion continues and even throughout
the year at our regional summits and see
you then